طيب شكرا جزيلا تدكس ودمدني بفتخر جدا انا
لاول مره اشارك في ود مدني في تيدكس شكرا
لحضوركم الجميل انا مصعب حسونه مخرج وصانع
افلام
حبيت الليله اشارك حضوركم الجميل بتجربتي
او تجربتنا مبادره تدريب الاطفال لصناعه
الفيلم ممكن ناس يكون سمعوا بها وناس ما
سمعوا بها فع اي حال دي مبادره تدريب
الاطفال لصناعه
الفيل
طيب الصوره دي
بخر
فيها وانا ري لا
سنوات الناس كلها مركزه مع العرس
زغاري الافراح لكن انا مركز مع حاجه واحده
معصور ماسك الكاميرا يعني لو ملاحظين بس
بتفرج مع
الكاميرا احساس غريب جدا وانت بتشوف زول
اني شايل ال كاميرا وانت طفل نفسك وم عينك
بس تهبش الكاميرا دي وشوف
تشتغل كبيره جدا وصعب انه انت تقوللي زول
كبيرد الكاميرا ده انا داير اصور مثلا او
الدنيا اشوفه كيف بتعمل وت عمرك ممكن يكون
ثلاثه سنه او اربع
سنه الحاجه دي خلتني ان اكبر شويه وانا
عندي علاقه باللام بشكل
عام ظهرت الحاجه دي وانا اكبر شويه لما
فرصه انه اكون مقدم لبرامج الاطفال بقدم
فقره واحده فقره واحده في اذاعه بقول اسم
الفقره كمان في البدايه بقول فقره مثلا
فقره الرسائل بكتفي بك وبكون مبسوط جدا
برجع البيت وانا مبسوط انه انا الليله
عملت حاجه كويسه جدا عملت حاجه انا بحبها
يعني انا مشيت وتكلمت يعني في
الاذاعه دي كانت برض بالنسبه لي خطوه مهمه
في حياتي وما ممكن انساها باي شكل من
الاشكال خلتني لقدام انه انا افكر يعني
بعد ما مشيت الثانوي انه انا داير اعمل
حاجه استمتع معاه جدا وفي نفس الوقت احاول
انه اضيف بها حاجه للناس الثانيين اللي
بيعرفوني طيب جت
الفرصه عمري ما حلمت بها انه انا اكون
مقدم لبرامج الاطفال تم تقديم او فرص
للتقديم لسبعه شباب من الوطن العربي انهم
يكونوا مقدمين في برنامج في قناه الجزيره
للاطفال في السودان لما جوا عملوا
المعاينات كانوا الشباب اللي قدموا انهم
يكونوا مقدمين لبرامج الاطفال اكثر من 150
شاب انا مشيت في اليوم الاخير عرفت في
اليوم الاخير ومشيت في نفس اليوم الاخير
لكن بس اصرار من وعزي انشي اشارك كنت امشي
اقدم اقدم في المعاينات بعد اسبوع من
المعاينات انا نسيت فكره انه انا قدمت
اصلا خلاص ان انا قدمت في ناس في 150
قدامي لكن الحمد لله تم اختيارك ضمن من
الوطن العربي عشان ما يقدموا برنامجح على
قناه الجزيره لاطفال الحمدلله ما
ودي كانت بالنسبه لي بوابه كبيره انه انا
امشي بها اكثر واحترف في مجال الاعلام
فعلا انا درست كليه الموسيقى والدراما
ودرست الراديو والتلفزيون لكن اشوف الخطوه
الثانيه اللي انا مشيتها في حياتي اللي هي
العمل الطوعي اجهت للعمل الطوعي واشتغلت
في مبادرات وجمعيات ومنظمات عندها علاقه
بالشباب مجتمع بشكل عام منها برامج عندها
علاقه بصيانه المدارس عندها علاقه بالنفير
في الاحياء وغيرها لكن بالنسبه لي ما
كانت التجربه دي هي الكافيه وهي المحطه
اللي انا ممكن يعني اقيف فيها لانه انا
بقيت امام تحدي كبير جدا انا زول متخصص في
مجال كيف انا اقدر اتطوع بحرفيه و بمهنيه
يعني الحاجه اللي انا قريتها كيف اقدر
اخدم بها مجتمعي من خلال تخصص ب عينه ومن
هنا بدا التفكير مع اصحابي اللي انا يعني
هم شروع حياتي اللي هم الاطفال كيف اقدر
اعمل حاجه الاطفال دي ممكن هم يستفيدوا
منها في حياتهم بشكل عام وانا اكون يعني
مبسوط ومستمتع معاهم يعني
طيب الحصل شنو الحصل انه في بيوتنا بنشوف
الاطفال يعني عندهم شغف بتاع انه دايرين
يصوروا ب موبايلاتنا دايرين يخدموا
اللابتوبات دايرين اذا في كاميرا في البيت
عايزين يعني يستغلوها انه يصوروا بها وفي
احيان كثيره احيان كثيره جدا بيكون في رفض
من الاسر انه يعني يا ولد التلفون يا بن
خذ الكاميرا دي هناك او اقفل اللاب توب
مثلا في احيان كثيره جدا بتحصل بحجه انه
هم ما بيعرفوا لا الحاجات دي لسه مثلا في
احيان كثيره بتحصل ف البحص شنو لو اديناهم
فرصه
انه يصوروا مثلا او اذا بحبوا يمنتج ندم
فرصه انه مثلا يستخدموا جهاز المونتاج من
هنا جت الفكره انه تدعم
مبادره عشان ما الاطفال دول يتدربوا على
انه يصنعوا فيلم ماله لو صنعوا فيلم لما
طرحت الفكره دي على ناس كثيرين جدا من
ضمنهم شباب من ضمنهم ناس كبار قالوا يا
اخي القصه دي صعبه جدا في السودان هنا
بالذات احنا ياداب دايرين نحاول يعني تكون
في مبادرات شبابيه دايرين الناس الكبار
عندهم افلام دايرين يقدموها وكذا شنو
الاطفال ال تجي تحشر لنا في النص تقول انه
يصنعوا افلام اطفال شنو بيقدروا يعمل
الحجه شوف حاجه غيره ثانيه لكن يعني
بصراحه لانه في النهايه دي انا مؤمن بهم
جدا مؤمن بانه الاطفال ممكن يعملوا حاجه
وحاجه يعني فيها اضافه للناس يعني
وللمجتمع وفي نفس
الوقت بيقدروا يعبروا بها عن حاجات كثيره
جدا هم ما ما بيقولوها قول ممكن من خلال
صوره يصور له صوره جميله يقدر يعبر بها
فجت هنا الفرصه بتاعتي انه تتيح يعني تكون
في تحه فرصه للاطفال دي
طيب بعد كده الحصل شنو اه الحاجه ده انا
حعملها كيف ودايره قروش كتيره جدا عشان ما
انت تدرب لك
اطفال محتاج انك يكون عندك قروش كثيره جدا
ومحتاج انك يكون عندك مواد تشتغل عليها
وكده لكن عندنا السوشيال ميديا انا عندي
السوشيال ميديا وعندي اصحاب كثيرين جدا
يعني بعرف اصحاب وبعرف عندي اصدقاء
وصديقات وكده ممكن انا من خلال صفحتي
الشخصيه اعمل اعلان فعلا اذا عمل اعلان في
صفحتين انه انا داير ادرب الاطفال الا
اعمارهم ما بين 8 سنه ل 16 سنه انه كيف
يصنعوا افلام الكلام ده كان في يوم واحد
واحد ومن يوم واحد واحد هي ده كان
1/125 ده اول يوم انا افكر جاد انه انا
داير اعمل في يوم واح واحد ده
حاجه مختلفه يعني يعني حاجه تصهر باي شكل
من الاشكال تصهر للاطفال ل انه هم
يستفيدوا منها يعني تكون في حاجه حق
الاطفال
حقتهم في الصفحه الناس بدات تتفاعل شويه
شويه 10 15 لايك
بدينا المبادره في يوم 7 واحد اللي تقدموا
للتدريب اللي تقدموا بس للتدريب اكثر من
300 طفل دي رسلوا في الخاص مع اهلهم يعني
اهلهم رسل قال احنا عندنا فلانه الفلاني
او فلانه الفلانيه عايزين يتدربوا لكن
لانه الموضوع ما فيه ميزانيه بيبقى صعب
انك انت تدرب لك 200 طفل او 300 طفل
باختصار شديد اخترنا ال 16 طفل دي اعمارهم
ما بين زي ما قلت لكم من 8 سنه ل 16 سنه
بعد كده بقى موضوع المتطوعين اللي
هيشتغلوا في التدريب معي لانه يستحيل انا
ادرب لي 16 طفل على عناصر بناء الفيلم
يعني كلها تصوير ومونتاج واخراج وكتابه
سيناريو واعداد فريق
وغيره ومع ده كله كان عندي حاجه واحده انا
بمتلكها عندي اللاب توب بتاعي لاب توب
احمر اي زول بيعرفه لاب توب واحد لاب توب
وعندي كاميرا صغيره جدا يعني ما ممكن انا
يعني اقدر اشتغل عليها لفتره طويله جدا دي
الحاجات اللي عندي انا ما عندي اي قروش
غيرها كيف انا حاقدر
اشتغل تجربه زي دي يعني انا ما عندي شركه
واقفه معاي ما عندي جمعيه ما في غيره في
هو الكمبيوتر ده وفي الكاميرا الموجوده دي
انا حاقدر اشتغل عليها ولا يعني هل اتراحه
من الفكره اللي انا اصلا مؤمن بها ده ما
حصل الحصل انه انا استغليت المواد اللي
عندي دي وبدينا التدريب الاول بمعاونه من
من اساتذه هم اصدقاء انا بفتكرهم هم يعني
امنوا بالفكر انه نحنا بنجي ان شاء الله
ندي لك محاضرتين ثلاثه والاسماء كثيره من
الاص قال اللي كانوا واقفين في التجربه
المدربين اللي انتم شايفينهم دي جزوا منهم
وانا بحيهم جدا يعني اي واحد شاف الاعلان
بتاع ان احنا بدينا الورشه اليوم الاول
اليوم الثاني اليوم العاشر بدوا يرسلوا في
الخاص انه ن احنا دايرين ندرب في الحاجه
الفلانيه ومن هنا بيبقى الاحساس الصادق
بتاع انك انت تبادر وتخلي الاخرين هم
يقتنعوا بالحاجه اللي انت دار تعملها
ويمشوا معاك يعني بدل ما انت تمشي لزول
الناس الثانيين يجوا عشان ما يدربوا
معك
طيب دي مجموعه بعت الاطفال اخترناهم
للتدريب عشان ما هم يعني يتدربوا التدريب
بدا
بالمرحله النظر ان هم كيف انهم يعملوا
سيناريو كيف الاطفال ديل يعني يتدربوا
عليه ان يكتبوا سيناريو ده كان اول حاجه
نحنا اشتغلنا عليها كيف هم يفكروا في انه
يكتبوا قصه القصه دي بعد شويه حولوها
لسيناريو يعني قصه بيحكو لبعض بعد شويه
تتحول لسيناريو حقتهم القصص دي مؤلفين
الاطفال دي
انفسهم دي مرحله
السيناريو المرحله اللي بعديه كانت
التصوير يتدربوا على التصوير ودي كانت
مرحله بالنسبه لهم مهمه شديد نحنا ننتهي
من السيناريو عشان نمشي للتصوير عشان
الكاميرات دي نشتغل عليها اهلهم كانوا
مستغربين انه ده شنو الزول اللي بيدي له
كاميرا لاطفال ممكن يبوظو ممكن تخسر كانوا
بيجوا كثير جدا اهلهم بيتفرجوا عليهم وفي
احيان كثيره جدا الكاميرا بتعطل لكن
الحاجه دي ما كان لازم تواجه بعنف بالعكس
تواجه بانه الكاميرا تعطلت ونحنا حنقي في
يومين وبيحصل بينق في يومين من التدريب
وبيكونوا اخذوا درس جديد انه نحنا لو
الحاجات دي الكاميرا واللابتوب عطلنا
الورشه حتقف ما حيكون عندنا شغل ودي فيها
درس لهم هم للاهتمام بحاجاتهم وحاجات
الغير فعلا انتهت مرحله التصوير التدريب
على التصوير انتقلنا طوالي للمونتاج بنفس
جهاز المونتاج اللي انتم شايفينه ده نحنا
اشتغلنا عليه يتدربوا عليه الاطفال على
انه كيف هم يمنتج المواد اللي هيشتغلو
بعدين او الافلام اللي هيشتغلو طيب خطوه
الثالثه اللي هي التمثيل في اطفال كانوا
شغوفين بانهم يمثلوا ودايرين يطلعوا في اي
فيلم من الافلام كان عندهم شغف بمعاونه
بعض الاساتذه اللي عندهم علاقه بالتمثيل و
يعني عندهم رغبه انهم يشتغلوا مع الاطفال
اللي هم اصلا بادروا من ضمنهم الاستاذه
هند زمراوي وانا بحيه جدا قدرنا انه ننتهي
من مرحله التمثيل وبعديه كانت فنيه الصوت
يعني الاطفال ادرب على انه المكسرات انواع
الفيدهات انواع المايكات بشكل ممكن يحيروك
في ان هم بيعرفوها وبيعرفوا يشتغلوا عليها
كمان لانه امام تحدي قدام الناس الكبار
ديل انه انتوا لو ما
عرفتوا نحنا هنوقف منكم مثلا التدريب حقيف
لو ما عرفتوا تستخدموا الحاجات دي صح ان
احنا ما هنديكم فرصه انه
تزوروا يعني الحتات اللي احنا مشيناها
لانه احنا مشينا اذاعات كل مره بنمشي
اذاعه بجازف لنا قروش بتاع هايس كده ولا
كريز و الاطفال كلهم بنمشي وستوزع من اي
ذاع ان احنا ين ندرب الاطفال ديل
عل المكسرات مثلا انواع المكسرات طيب
الخطوه اللي بعدها الاخراج الاطفال تدربوا
على انه كيف المخرج يقود الفريق بتاعه كيف
المخرج يختار الشخصيات كيف يكون هو مخرج
قائد اداري يقدر يعني الاطفال المعو
التانين ديل يديهم حق في انهم يتكلموا
يعبروا يختار الممثلين صح دي كلها من
الحاجات اللي يدربوا عليها الاطفال الحاجه
الصوره اللي انتم شايفينها دي
عندها يعني ذاكره في ذاكرت انا ما حنساها
يعني الصوره اللي انتم شايفينها دي وغيرها
اللي هي احنا بعد ما انتهينا من التص من
التدريب العملي بقت عندنا مشكله صعبه جدا
في كان عندنا مقر مستضاف في واحده من
المعاهد اللي بتشتغل مع الاطفال ورحلوا
بقى ما عندهم قاعه المحل الثاني مشيناه
بعد شويه ناس الحته اللي مشينا نشتغل فيها
قالوا انه الاطفال شويه مزعجين وما حنقدر
نكمل هنا شوف لكم مكان اشتغلوا عليه ولما
كلمت الاطفال قالوا لي احنا ستحيل نقيف
احنا مكان يا جماعه ما عندنا مقر قالنا في
الشجر ده بنشتغل
قال احنا الشجر ممكن لاننا حبنا الح جدا
وفعلا زي ما شايفين في اول صوره قاعدين في
شجره بمنتج لانه كان الوقت دا الافلام
بتاعتهم اختاروها اختاروا موضوعات يشتغلوا
عليها وجت مرحله المونتاج وبقى ما في مكان
ففعلا نحنا في رحله بحث مستمر على انه
نلقى مكان نشتغل عليه لغايه ما الافلام دي
انتهت مره بكون في بيت ناس واحد من
الاطفال مره في الشارع مره بنشوف لنا
مكتبه بنمشي بنقعد فيها بنشتغل فعدت
الخطوه المهمه جدا اللي هي انه الناس
تشتغل الافلام اللي هي كانت 13 فيلم قصير
بتتراوح ما بين خمسه لسبعه دقائق من تصوير
ومونتاج وكتابه سيناريو واخراج الاطفال
بانفسهم فاي زول كان لما تقول له او يشوف
بوست في الفيسبوك انه الاطفال ديل هم
صنعوا افلام وعايزين نعرضها الناس كانوا
مستغربين جدا انه كيف اطفال اعمارهم اقل
من 16 سنه يعملوا افلام افلام ما بتتناقش
ما بتناقش اي موضوع بتناقش موضوعات عندها
علاقه باهمال الاطفال عندها علاقه
بالاطفال والزهور عندها علاقه برعايه
الوالدين للاطفال عندها علاقه بالاطفال
العماله موضوعات تحسسك ان الاطفال دول
فعلا هم حاسين باطفال تانيين ودايرين
يتكلموا عن موضوعات عند علاقه بالمجتمع
معناه من سن زي دي كده لما يبدوا يتحملوا
المسؤوليه تجاه مجتمعهم تجاه انفسهم لقدام
ممكن يكون يعني ده جيل ن احنا ننتظر منه
الكثير
يعني وبقت المرحله القبل الاخيره والمهمه
جدا اللي هي عرض الافلام بقت في 13 فيلم
عملوها لاطفال اهلهم متابعين التجربه دي
تماما لكن كيف ان احنا نعرض الافلام دي
وين بقى ده السؤال الكبير وجينا نفتش وما
عندنا قروش لاخر لحظه نحنا بفتش على مكان
نعرض فيه والفلام دي من غير ماحنا ندفع
قروش لصاله ولا قاعه لانه ما في قروش بنا
نفتش اي محل نمشي له اي اي شرك احنا مشينا
ليها ققول لنا والله التجربه دي غريبه ما
سمعنا بها وما بنقدر نخاطر اننا جز منها
لانه ممكن ما يجي جمهور مثلا ممكن الناس
ما تجي عديل في ناس بيقوللك ان احنا ما ما
مقتنعين ممكن ما يجينا جمهور
يعني اللي انتم بتعملوه ده نحنا ما نحنا
غايته تعال المره الجايه كثير جدا بقولنا
تعالوا المره الجايه ان احنا ما استسلمنا
على انه احنا ننتظر تاني سنه او نفكر كثير
بقينا بنشتغل بنظام الشير من اهل الاطفال
الاطفال ذاتهم دفعوا يعني اه
بدوا يتبرعوا عملوا شير في ما بينهم لغايه
ما نحنا عملنا هول اجرنا قاعه الناس اللي
كانوا بيقولوا لنا انه ما جمهور واحد منهم
جا بقى قاعد اخر الساله قاللي انا جيت وما
لقيت محل اقعد فيه واحد من مد المسؤول
المجتمعيه الكبار جدا في البلد يقولي انا
جيت اخر القاعه وما لقيت مكان اقعد فيه
عشان كده اذا من بكره انتم عايزين محل اذا
انتم من بكره ين تعملوا اي حاجه تعالوا ان
احنا معكم بعد الحجه شفنا
باختصار شديد القاعه بتشيل 500 لكن اليوم
ذاك شالت اكثر من 950 كيف انا ما ع اضافه
للناس اللي قاعدين بره في اكثر من 1500
نفر ديل يتصلوا والقاعدين يعني ينتظروا
بره على انه تجي يعني يكون في شاشات
خارجيه عشان ما تتعرض فيها الافلام ما في
اكثر من 1500 جو وفي ناس بيرجعوا لانه
القاعه اتملت تماما القاعه قدر القاعه دي
بالضبط كده اتملت تماما وفي ناس واقفين
لانه ما في مكان لانه العرض بصراحه كان 13
فيلم اي فيلم متش كان اكثر من الفيلم
البعديه
طيب التجربه ال بعديها واللي هي خلت يعني
خلتني ان نؤمن تماما انه التجربه دي ماشيه
كويس وحفزت شديد اللي هي في نفس يوم
الاحتفال اللي كان بتاع تدشين الافلام انه
ظهرت حاجه اسمها مؤسسه اضف الرقميه في
القاهره دي بالتعاون مع السودان فيلم
فاكتوري قالوا ان احنا مختارين اربعه
اخترنا اربعه من الاطفال ديول انه يشاركوا
في مخيمات اضف الرقميه في القاهره لمده
شهر على حسابنا ودي كانت برضو بالنسبه
للاطفال محفزه جدا انه اربعه مننا ولدين
وبنتين لانه الافلام بتاع كل الاطفال كانت
يعني ادهشهم جدا انه الاربعه ديول هيمشوا
يشاركوا في معسكرات اضف الرقميه في
القاهره وهي محفزه جدا بالنسبه للمبادره
وبالنسبه للاطفال لاهلهم ان هم بيعملوا في
حاجه سمحه ممكن يستفيدوا منها كل ناس بشكل
عام طيب
دي صور الاطفال اللي اتقدمت بعد كده بعد
ما يتقدم العرض الاول ان احنا قدمنا في
اكثر من 17 17 مركز صقافي في الخرطوم ديل
قالوا عايزين المبادره تنتقل لهم وهم يعني
تتقدم المبادره ويجي الجمهور يحضر و فعلا
اقل عرض من العروض اللي احنا قدمناها ممكن
ما اقل من 250 من المشاهدين الج حضروا
تجربه مبادره تدريب الاطفال لصناعه الفيلم
اللي هي حفزت الاطفال واهلهم انه هم يعني
يجوا يشاركوا في الدورات الثانيه طيب
بالنسبه للسوشيال ميديا الاطفال بيقوا
برضه يتدربوا على انهم يعملوا الصفحه بتاع
المبادره هم عملوا الصفحه اللي انتم
شايفينها دي وهم في نفس الوقت عملوا
الجروب في الواتساب مع اهلهم يعني جروب
مشترك فيه اهلهم او اهلهم بيخشوا و بيدوهم
التلفونات انه يتواصلوا في الجروب ما
بينكم بالاضافه الى
موقع المبادره اللي عملوه في البدايه كان
عباره عن 500
600 شخص كان بيجي بيشاهد المبادره بيعمل
لايك الان الصفحه في ماشيه على
5800 مشاهد بشكل مستمر جدا د بيخشوا
وبيعرفوا اخبار المبادره بشكل مستمر فدي
حاجه كانت محفزه لنا جدا يعني الان احنا
بنصمم في الويب سايت بتاع المبادره وقريب
جدا ح يكون الويب سايت متوفر وفي
الفضاء الحاجه الثانيه
وال ملهمه بالنسبه لنا جدا ومحفزه اللي هي
افلام
الانيميشن الانيميشن جت واحده فرنسيه
خبيره قالت انها شافت الافلام دي بعد ما
جات السودان شافت الافلام وعندها الرغبه
انها تدرب معان وتطوع زول خبيره في مجال
الانيميشن فقالت عايزه تعمل ورشه للاطفال
وفعلا اخترنا 20 من الاطفال انه يتدربوا
كيف يعملوا افلام رسوم متحركه يتدربوا على
التكنيك على انه هم يعملوا افلام حصلت
الحاجه دي فعلا
اختل ال 20 طفل بوا هسه الان موجودين ال
20 طفل بيعرفوا يشتغلوا تكنيك استخدام
افلام الرسوم المتحركه هم بانفسهم يعني
بعد ممكن يكون اقل من شهرين هيعملوا تجربه
ثلاثه افلام هم اللي يصنعوها يعني افلام
انميشن وصناعه
الاطفال
طيب
هو التناول الاعلامي بالنسبه
للمبادره حفزنا جدا بصراحه انه يعني اكثر
من 13 فضائيه دوليه ومحليه تلفزيونات
واذاعات اضافه الى الصحف الجات غطت
المبادره خلت انه اكثر من خمسه دول عربيه
تنقل التجربه لعندها بما فيها سوريا بما
فيها مصر بما فيها تونس الجزائر بما فيها
الامارات العربيه المتحده خمسه دول نقلت
التجربه اللي عندها وموجوده وموسه ان احنا
نقلنا تجربه مبادره تدريب الاطفال لدولنا
والان اكيد حتكون اطورت جدا جدا لانه
الامكانيات طبعا بتلعب دور كبير جدا
جدا ممكن نشوف جزء المبادره والتدريب بشكل
عام
اش
tion
tion tion
action
action
heart
be col and
pr how to
be
can
when
to fall but watching you
stand every breath
every has come to
this
one i died
every for you daring don't be i led you
for i love you
for
more time
stand bey
and i will
be
طيب ولسه في المبادره
احنا مستمرين ولغايه الان ان احنا في حماس
في طاقه كبيره جدا انه ان احنا الشباب ما
حدف في طريقنا عقبه و حتجي في طريقنا
مشاكل ماليه طالما عندنا افكار عندنا
دايره بتاع اصدقاء ممكن نستفيد منهم ما
حتكون عندنا مشكله تانيه لقدام طالما انه
في طفل بيجيك من الخرطوم عشان ما يحضر
تدكس هنا زي ما حصل مع محمود عبد الله
البلال موجود هنا جم خرطوم مخصوص عشان ما
يحضر السيشن ده وهو محمود موجود معانا ان
احنا بنح شديد طالما
في وهو ده نموذج لاطفال كثيرين جدا محمود
ابو قبل شويه بيقول لي كل ما نحنا ننزل
صوره واحده في الصفحه بتاعتنا محمود كان
بيعمل لها داونلود وبنزله في الكمبيوتر
بتاعه وتمني اللحظه اللي بتجي وانه يكون
واحد من الاطفال اللي بيشاركوا في
المبادره في السنه الجايه اللي هي هتكون
بعد ايام ان شاء
الله شكرا جزيلا
لسد شكرا للشباب الخرطوم برض عشان ما
يحضروا هندوسه والراني عينان سي شكرا كثير
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله